>> John: HERE WE GO ON, ANDBE.
FOR THE RIGHT IN FRONT, KNOCK ID
THE BOARDS.
THROWN TO THE NET FOR TOFFOLI,
SKATE, SID
[ Horn  SHOOTER.
FIRES THREE PN UP.
DVORAK FOR CHIAROT.
BACK OF THE NET FOR HOFFMAN,
LOTS OF ROOM FOR IT.ASCORES!
A NICE GOAL  COMES OUT FRONT,
LEHNER THE STOP.
TOFFOLI STICKS IN THE REBOUND,D
WIDE OPEN NET AND THEY CAN'T
BANG
ALEX PIETRANGELO WITHN THETWO-O.
IT'S HOFFMAN,FRONT,
SCORES!
JONATHAN MARCHESSAULT KNOCKS IT
HOME, AND VEGAS HAS TIED STABS H
THE BACK OF HIS STICK UP OVER I
THE SEASON.
ANOTHER POWER PLAY GOAL, AND TH
RIPS RIGHT BY HIM AND THE VEGAS
GOLDEN KNIGHTS, AS YOU CAN SEE,
JAMMING AT IT AND HE'LL
DOWN YOUR OPPONENT
>> John: CHANDLER STEPHENSON
DOWN THE WING WITH A SHOT.IOD AS
HAD TO IT FOR
RIGHT IN FRONT, CHANCE TO THE YT
TO BE CAREFUL.
>> John: HERE'S
CHANDLER STEPHENSON TUCKS IT IN
AND MAKES IT 11th
POINT.
HE SLIDES THIS INTO THE OPEN NET
DVORAK WITH A CHANCE, BRAYDEN M
SMASHING HIS STICK AND THEN